hey guys it's me mark so you might have
a lot of questions um why is this not a
list video why is this not a breakdown
in our analysis of some description and
I decided to change it up just for this
week I'll be going back to like the
regular scheduled programming next week
but I figured this week I'd like to show
you guys what I like to do before I made
this YouTube channel I actually was
studying animation and wanted to become
an illustrator or animator and still do
a little bit but this is just something
that I just kind of wanted to make
because when I was a kid I was looking
for you know ways to draw different
Dragon Ball characters but they were
always in very specific ways the methods
that I found online like they people
would always like do this they'd
just draw the box thing and like like
that and like okay so what you want to
do is you want to draw it like this and
then like that like personally I don't
think that's very conducive to becoming
a better artist I think that's learning
how to draw a specific character in a
very specific way and it's very at least
I think it locks you down to doing one
specific thing so what I want to show
you today is how to draw not only Vegeta
Super Saiyan blue two but I wanted to
show you how you can draw any character
you want in any pose you want because
sometimes just the front view pose isn't
exactly very you know interesting to
look at alright so a lot of people when
they're drawing myself included I would
be very much like okay so I'll start
drawing this I like that
I'll do this oh yeah that's looking good
on to that and you know I'll do all
those different things and you know
eventually then you start like you lose
track of where you are relative like the
proportions don't work and the reasons
why the proportions don't work is it's
for a variety of reasons really but at
least for me when I was a kid it was it
was because I didn't have a clue about
Anatomy I didn't have any basic
understanding of all that kind of
you know and little face there
okay let's career that I didn't have a
basic understanding of anatomy and I
think that's a really common issue with
a lot of artists and upcoming artists
nowadays and the reason why I think it's
a problem is because
drawing an enemy is boring people want
to be able to draw their favorite
characters and they want to be able to
draw them you know well but nothing
worth having is ever easy to get so you
do have to practice and I have put in my
fair share of practice I have
sketchbooks filled with different life
drawings of pictures and people and
stuff like that so just to get this out
of the way I think this is the best way
for a beginner to approach drawing a
complex image but I'm just going to stop
talking just going to get into it so you
might notice that I have these two guys
on the left the top one is a very very
very good illustrator on Twitter I left
us his handle is right here below that I
found this pose online randomly I just
thought it was a very dynamic pose I
think that's x-23 but it's just some
sketch work done by this another very
talented artist whose Twitter handle is
right here so if you want to check them
out they're there so what I wanted to do
today is I wanted to show you not just
how to draw Vegeta but how to draw any
character in any pose it just happens
that today we're doing Vegeta I'm gonna
stop not drawing and I'm gonna show you
the the the method to which I came to
draw that character now I have all of
this done already I just want to show
you how to how I got there and I'll do a
little bit of drawing as well alright so
starting off okay so I have like a
folder with loads of little folders
inside so okay so the first thing it's
all about layers so you want to start by
doing a base layer and this is what a
base layer looks like so how I achieve
this - super important rules okay rule
number one always guess the line of
action so the lot so what's the line of
action the line of action is essentially
this line that's going straight down the
character and you want to be able to get
that when you have that at the very
least you have a strong grounded pose
and so that's what kind of makes the
pose have a bit more energy and a bit
more life to it
that line of action really helps make it
more dynamic I suppose is the word I'm
looking for so you want to have line of
action if it fits in there it does cool
and the second one I want to talk about
is this is the most important one I
think usually when people are drawing
something when they step away from it
and are finished with it and they don't
apply these rules
a lot of the time the proportions are
off or they're disjointed and they don't
fit together well it looks like a poorly
done drawing and trust me I've been
there
to combat this I use this method that a
lot of people use so you see how these
shoulders are just aligned so every
single pose has this so like I was
trying to use this pose as inspiration
for this one I adjusted it slightly
because he's a slightly larger frame but
this person here so you see these two
shoulders that there's a line so that
line would be like that it's like around
that same angle you have that and you
have the bigger shoulder and when you
have that line going through your line
of action those are your shoulders you
don't need to worry where your shoulders
are anymore I would draw this line here
I draw these two things and those are
the shoulders I don't need to worry
about where the shoulders are anymore
they are there so one last thing you
want to find out where the hips are so
there's a straight line going through
here so you want to go straight line and
then you find the hips now you can
forget about the shoulders you can
forget about the hips and because you
have those two things everything is
going to fit together so much nicer and
you don't need to try nearly as hard
that's one of the most important things
I think people forget when they're
drawing we're all a bunch of parts
amalgamated together so if you have an
idea of where the shoulders are relative
to the hips and the dirt and the angle
of which they are placed then you are in
a much better place than you would be
just guessing and this is one of the big
rules that helped me hugely yeah so you
what you want to do is you want to find
the shoulder shoulders and hips so
that's the first rule so when I had
those I was able to find and apply that
rule to pretty much everything and I got
my I got something that I was fairly
happy with those are my this is my base
sketch my initial proportion stuff right
right so after this I would build off of
this as then create a new layer or if
you're working on paper you can just you
know put another sheet over it and trace
over and the your rough sketches your
rough sketches come next and over and so
as you can see I applied them the rough
sketches to the initial skeleton work
and
as a result things are relatively in
proportion and that's pretty good
these hands the hands I just took these
are just my hands they're just pictures
that I took off my hand and you see the
line of action here too these are just
pictures I took of my hands and I would
draw them how I draw hands would be okay
let's just zoom in here so how I would
draw hands as you can see I would just
kind of get the basic shape of the hand
and then there are these little bits
here that would be where the the the
actual fingers are and then when you
have that you can just it it's much
easier to just go off of that then you
know like I don't want to make this
video about drawing hands but one thing
I want to get across is I'm not looking
at this drawing as one huge thing that I
need to get done it's just it's one
thing that is made up of a bunch of
small things and if I deal with each
individual small thing there first of
all much more manageable and second of
all it helps get everything done just a
little bit more smoothly so yeah so if
if I go back here and show you this I
got the head and so what I would just do
I would just lightly sketch you know
just around this here just like getting
like what I think is where his face and
everything should be I can adjust it all
later but um the whole point of this
rough sketch anyway was just to get an
idea you know there's like obviously a
lot of things that are wrong with this
but the whole point of this is to get
you to a point where doing the final
line work isn't a huge task it's
actually gonna be fun so for instance I
won't keep his face exactly like that
it's just a good example of where I want
the face to be so like actually look I
think a really good example of this is
the face so when I was drawing this face
I wanted to try to capture something
from this gentleman's put her sketches
but I didn't want to straight-up copy it
or trace it so what I actually did was I
opened up the character sheets for
Vegeta
for Dragon Ball super and I tried to
strike a middle ground between this man
sketch and the character designs that
are supplied by Toei animation for
Dragon Ball super and when I did that I
went and did my final line work and my
final line work looked something like
this
now there's a big jump here you might
think but it's actually not that much if
you look beneath here you can see that
my base sketch I've just tweaked slight
things off my base sketch and that's
really how this whole thing comes
together it's all just feeling it out
what looks right what doesn't look right
this isn't an impressive effort because
you know now what went into making it
it's all a building block process if I
was to tell you that I went from nothing
to this then yeah that's impressive and
there are some artists out there that
can do that and they're amazing
and they are genuinely good but now that
you know that I went from this to this
to this it's not as impressive anymore
because I'm showing you the process the
building blocks that went into making it
and that's all it is so I wanted to try
to hit a nice balance here between this
man's Vegeta and Toei animations Dragon
Ball super is Vegeta also and I think I
kind of like hid a little bit closer to
Dragon Balls super but I'm okay with I'm
actually very happy with the way the
face turned out it's nice and expressive
and I always like to add a little bit of
extra detail to the teeth as well I
don't know why just something I like to
do but yeah so like just to show you
just to give you a like a little example
of what I would do if I was actually
drawing this so like for instance like
if I was to draw this right I would like
I would make sure not to do this this is
I think something that a lot of artists
do because and I found out it's because
they are unsure of their lines and stuff
what you want to do and this is and this
will again improve your drawings 10
times more is make sure it's just one
solid line you know just to get just
just to make sure that it's just one
solid motion and you can do this a bunch
of times you know I mean you can do with
your rubber or all that kind of stuff
but it really does make a huge
difference with difference with your
with your with your illustrations
if you do that and you can tidy it up
and stuff but the whole point is just to
get a smooth consistent line that
doesn't look sketchy because again the
final line art shouldn't be sketchy you
know but yeah but like there are a lot
of things that you can do like you know
to make everything just that little bit
better like I mean I could make him like
super angry and all that kind of stuff
and that usually has to go into like the
eyes and the angle to which they're
being put out and stuff like you know
but there are there are a lot of things
that that you can do to make this stuff
work but it just takes time
and I think that's the thing that people
don't like about illustration people who
say they can't draw I don't believe that
I just believe it's all down to how much
time and how much effort you place into
the drawing so yeah so the final line
art was this and so with everything
removed this is where we are boom
this is where it is this is where we are
with the Vegeta drawing and so far
everything looks perfectly in proportion
because I applied those rules regarding
the shoulders the line of action still
there the hips are still there all that
stuff is still there those things that I
set up day one and because I set those
things up day one we have a solid sketch
or a solid final product there are a
bunch of different principles that play
hero I also kind of like fluff the hair
a bit because I like giving the hair a
bit of a volume so yeah there are a
bunch of different things at play here
so so let me give you an example right
here we have the shoulder thing right
this kind of shoulder strap that Vegeta
has so there are a lot of things that
can see yes so that there are a lot of
things here say and you want to be able
to know okay how do I get this stuff to
work together properly and to be honest
it's all about just practice you got so
like how do you make this thing look
three-dimensional now cuz you know you
have this thing and it's it's very flash
the whole point of the rough sketch is
just to give yourself an idea of where
you're gonna be putting all of this
detailing because you know when you're
the final liner is really where that
fine
drawing comes together so like for
instance with this right you would do
something like that and then you would
bring it over here maybe like I'm just
gonna do this really quick you do this
like that boom and then to make it look
3d you go bang like that and look all of
a sudden boom it's 3d you know you do
that all over the place you know just
like that and look and then just like
that boom is 3d and like you know it
does look half bad it's alright but like
okay it's kind of shitty but you know
but you get the point it's just a
collection of different drawing
practices that come with experience that
come with experience but again in saying
that I believe anyone can do this if
they want to enough you know like
learning how to do the creases and stuff
like these are just things that will
come over time and stuff you know but
yeah so we're at the final lineart stage
and the next stage then would be
coloring so boom we have color bang I
just pretty much took all of these
colors from an episode of super so
that's why everything looks decent there
but it's just a question of coloring in
the lines then that's fine
everything's good we're all gravy but
right now it looks like a very flat
image and it's not you know because we
have some force perspective here you'd
like to make it look more 3d and to make
it look more 3d add shading but before
you add shading you need to think about
where's the light source coming from so
when I was making this I wanted to have
you know these balls of energy coming
from his heads that means that there is
light coming from this side and this
side which means that the shadow will be
going cast right down the middle of his
body and so I did that with each
individual aspect of him so we'll start
with the hair so with the hair boom I
added this shading so again these are
all colors that I just took straight
from a next episode preview we have the
kind of this nice purple color but I
also had these kind of things in here as
well this isn't in super this is
something that I added because I just
thought it'd look cool
I don't know okay so some something
interesting here with the hair so the
light is here from his hands and it's
traveling this way therefore it will
cast a shadow and that's exactly what
I've done here this hair here cast a
shadow here and this hair here cast a
shadow here and that gives it a sense of
three dimensionality as I said before
which is what we're trying to get here
okay so moving on we have the blue
clothes boom
these are okay I think I could have done
this better but again I just you know
you loo you do lose enthusiasm so yeah
again all the shadows are kind of
working around the idea that from both
sides there's lice and like again it's
all about just playing around with it
seeing what works what doesn't work and
you know it's there there is a lot of
guesswork but again over time you'll
just become better at it moving down we
have the gold plating and stuff so yeah
I had the shadow here because this bit
of armor here kind of like juts out a
little bit so kind of like here but you
know I don't know how to explain it
towards the camera I suppose and that's
why there's a shadow there moving on to
the white clothing okay so I did that
because there's shadow here and so like
I'm going through the shading
individually just so that I can give you
guys an idea of why I did something I
think it's fine if you want to look at
some guy draw something but this is
really for people who just want to learn
how I do things and why I've done it
this way and the choices that I've made
and etc so yeah you'll see the hands
here this is kind of cool like I really
like doing the hands I do love drawing
hands actually it's more like it's one
of the things that a lot of people hate
so I I made sure that it's something
that I can do you'll see that the light
source is coming from the middle of a
hand and therefore the way the way light
moves it kind of bends around stuff
think of it like a bubble pressing
against a glass wall there's always
going to be a kind of a circular aspect
to it and so that's why everything here
seems to have like kind of like bendy
motion around it and it kind of it does
create a very realistic look to it I
think I'm very happy with the way that
turned out okay I give that like okay so
the last thing I want to show you guys
is the shadow for the skin boom all of a
sudden it looks so much better and it's
kind of come together as a drawing
because of that aspect now I kind of
copied Takahashi's thing here because it
looks kind of cool but other than that
this this is just three tone shading so
we have the normal base tone we have a
shadow tone and we have a darker shadow
tone that are used sparingly but yeah
this is something that you can just copy
directly off like again I popped a
reference from like Dragonball Z or
episode 122 for this specifically and
that's pretty much it so what
when I was a kid there weren't any
drawing tutorial specifically for how to
draw Dragon Ball characters so I had to
learn myself so I'm hoping that these
tips and tricks and I'm hoping to
instill a few principles in people that
like this is how you draw and this is
how you should draw there's no right and
wrong way of drawing but this way
definitely helps if you don't have a
grasp on anatomy yet and I certainly
don't you look at that arm it looks
weird so I hope you found this
insightful for the four people that are
left watching for the others that
weren't interested in this you know I'll
be making regular videos again next week
but this is just something that I wanted
to show you guys how I made this
character and with this character then
you can you know you can just add stuff
to it so like I added stuff like I don't
know effects I added I added like
lightning and stuff and some kind of
blasts to his hands a fella I thought
that looked kind of cool you know I kind
of gave him an outer or with kind of
like the sparkles and stuff and then you
can just like you know throw in a
background boom then all of a sudden you
have like a scene and that looks fine
then you know like if you were to look
at this picture you think oh okay
and I would be too I'd be like I have no
idea how to start this thing I
guess I'll just start drawing and hope
for the best
that is not what you want to do what you
want to do is as follows you want to
find where the shoulders are and join
them up and at the correct angle find
where the hips are and join them up and
then find the line of action and then
find the line of action when you have
those things you are in an infinitely
better position than you were before I
know I've been kind of all over the
place with this but this is essentially
just what I wanted to get across you
guys
and I hope that so at least some of you
found that helpful the G is one of my
favorite characters
Super Saiyan blue - looks
awesome and if you guys would like me to
draw anything else and show you how to
draw it then I can do that but really
I'm gonna go back to my normal
programming next week and I hope you
guys enjoyed this video
it's a one-off I didn't script anything
obviously and I'm apologizing for being
sort of all over the place here but this
is just something that I just wanted to
do for the community and hopefully some
guys out here found it helpful so
this is how you draw Dragon Ball
characters and pretty much any character
you want really so I will see you guys
next week bye